[Music]
hello fellow anime lovers in this video
we're going over 10 anime that will take
you on an unexpected emotional journey
every show on the list will have you in
tears of joy or sadness so buckle down
and get ready for the first anime on the
list
he knows the kikiyaon I don't know
she knows the cure meters they want to
settle up at number 10 it's a raised a
raised is a relatable anime that focuses
on self-reflection within the heart and
mind the main protagonist Satoru is
depicted as a depressed 29 year old who
doesn't open up to people and doesn't
have any close friends however he's a
good person who's willing to go that
extra mile to help people in danger the
game-changer in this series is how the
main character undergoes a phenomenon
called revival this typically puts the
main character back in time whenever
something bad happens erased is a unique
anime because it showcases crimes that
happen around the main character as he
struggles to ultimately change destiny
by rewriting events in order to prevent
tragedy Satoru
[Music]
[Music]
number nine we have an Ohana ana Hana is
a show about emotional high school
students coming to terms with guilt and
dealing with their struggles similar to
erased the main character doesn't have
many friends in the beginning of the
series and feels like he isn't noticed
by anyone even at school he's the
definition of an introvert he used to
have a ton of friends back in the day
but once his childhood friend Menma and
his mum passed away everything changed
he started slacking in school and failed
all of his exams putting him in the
lowest tier schools within the area one
day he actually sees men mind his house
and thinks he's hallucinating until he
starts interacting with her this show
really touches home with nostalgic
feelings of the past with flashbacks of
wholesome memories with everyone as kids
when life was easier this anime is great
because you can see the change in clique
dynamics as the plot progresses when the
high school students retrace their steps
into their forgotten and bonds of
friendship
[Music]
Hana oregan an emu at number eight its
wolf children when a werewolf man and
human woman love each other very much
they make cute tiny werewolf babies
apparently and then dad gets himself
killed leaving one human parent to raise
two tiny wolf monstrosity x' note we
aren't calling them monstrosity is
because they're wolves we're calling
them that because they're babies poor
mom is on her own with these little
handfuls as they're constantly switching
between their human and wolf forms one
of the children Yuki begs her mum to let
her participate in school while the
other arm a is more interested in the
forest and ends up taking lessons from a
fox about surviving in the wild this is
a very emotional story because it shows
the perspective of a mother caring for
her children and watching them go their
separate ways growing up it illustrates
an emphasis on building relationships
and Trust as they have to hide their
true wolf identities from the public
while figuring out what they want to do
with their lives matter there at number
7 it's the garden of words the garden of
words is a short story about 15 year old
school boy to cow a Kazuki he doesn't
stand out much at school and has a
passion for shoemaking the anime puts a
lot of emphasis on soft piano melodies
and it sets the tone for the setting and
what's to come one day took our decides
to skip school when it's raining and go
and sit in a park here he meets Miss
Yuki know a woman who's skipping work
because of personal problems and he
eventually forms a strong connection
with her Kakao would always look forward
to whenever it rained because they would
both skip their responsibilities to hang
out the main protagonist confesses to
miss Yuki know that all he wants to do
is become a great shoe maker and then he
promises to make her a new pair of shoes
eventually the rainy season comes to an
end and he doesn't see her for months
but she's constantly on his mind
Yuki knows tale is a depressing one as
it spurs
the main protagonists emotions to stand
up for who he believes her to be so
logical since a while she's so Connie
Cox our data bang arsenal Sergio sue
Romano our Kanazawa rookie Dudley cocoa
Roll Morton a tunnel donut at number 6
we have violet ever garden violet ever
garden begins with a girl named violet
who's been in hospital for four months
after the war at first her hands are
bandaged
but it's then revealed that her arms are
made of adamant steel when she spills
hot tea on them at her new home in the
ever Garden estates violet is taken in
by the lieutenant who shows her the
ropes ultimately violet decides to
become an auto memory doll who can write
letters for people working in the same
building violet doesn't feel emotions
like everyone else and has trouble
learning what it means to feel them to
go through the story trying to learn the
ways of the world not as a tool meant
for destruction but as a normal human
being that can comprehend and understand
feelings it's a great anime that
everyone should look into if you like
great animations music and complex plots
about self-expression the music and
animation is beautifully creative and it
does well to heighten the sombre setting
of the post-war time period
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
at number five we have your lie in April
your lie in April is a beautifully
animated love story based around a piano
playing prodigy named Chris a he's a 14
year old boy who's determined to make
sure no one ever falls in love with him
although he's just a middle schooler the
light in his eyes has been taken away
because of his mother's death as opposed
to his friend Tsubaki who sees a world
full of color he sees everything in
monotone just like music scores and
keyboards despite it being his mother's
dream to raise him to be a world-class
pianist he's having a hard time coming
to terms with playing after being abused
by his mother and her passing the
protagonist then meets a beautiful girl
named Kaori who ultimately changes his
outlook on life as she challenges him to
cope with the past and play music again
The Situation's portrayed in this show
are emotional roller coasters that
illustrate how you can overcome anything
if you set your mind to it
this show does an outstanding job to
keep you as entertained by contrasting
kassay self-doubt with the positive
support from his classmates although
here
Hasegawa be sort of allotted a you may
not get you know yard
at number four we have your name your
name is an endearing tale of fate and
love beautifully animated and brimming
with emotion plugging details that are
sure to have you laughing crying or a
solid mix of the two the main characters
are genuine and easy to fall in love
with right off the bat with their
dialogue providing an atmosphere to the
story and insight into the way they live
their lives the two characters centered
in this complicated relationship are
high schoolers Mitsu ha and tacky both
of whom live vastly different lives
Mitsu ha serves as a dancing shrine
maiden in her rural mountain town while
taki waits on tables at a bustling
upscale restaurant in tokyo they meet
each other through an odd supernatural
phenomenon in which periodically when
they wake up they've swapped bodies it's
not something they have control over so
they do their best not to royally mess
up one another's livelihoods they even
manage to make some improvements along
the way the timing couldn't have been
better for their fates to cross as major
events challenged them to push the
limits of what they can do as
individuals this movie is definitely one
that everyone should see if you enjoy
watching love stories showcased in a
creative way or at all
Tomodachi
the reticle
at number three a silent voice also
known as the shape of voice this teen
drama starts off on a heavier note with
lead Shia Ishida in the edge of a bridge
about to jump to his death as he comes
to his senses we flashback and begin to
relieve Ishida's elementary school days
as a bully
all of which started when the class was
introduced to new students sho corner
shamea a deaf girl who recently
transferred but was just trying her best
to live a normal life and fit in as for
the plot we don't want to give too much
away because the real story unfolds from
the emotions and the actions of each
individual character and the battles
they fight within their selves and with
their inner demons the recurring themes
of coming to terms with uncontrollable
transformations formed over the years of
each character's experiences and how it
challenges each of their own unrelenting
standards of themselves is the real
story here the film isn't afraid to make
you feel emotions a lot of other movies
and stories are too afraid to touch I
hope you find the time to experience
this one for yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
at number two we have grave of the
fireflies grave of the fireflies is a
studio ghibli classic that turns away
magic and fantasy to reveal the gruesome
realities of the war the story takes
place during world war ii and showcases
the struggle of sibling Seita and
Setsuko who must fend for themselves in
a world of fire bombs and famine from
burns to beatings to psychological
distress grave of the fireflies shows a
darker side to humanity as well as its
light catch it during Ghibli fest if
your local theaters host it and be sure
to know what you're getting into with
this movie fellow snot Fawcett Criers
please bring copious amounts of tissues
because this one is an absolute
tearjerker
[Music]
kua normativity Ida
but they only the asymmetry domina and
finally at number one Clannad and
Clannad after story Clannad starts off
with a rather depressing tone with
phrases such as I hate this town and how
it's filled with too many memories that
the main protagonist would rather forget
he wonders if his mundane boring
lifestyle will ever change and then he
meets a shy girl talking to herself on
the way home named Farouk oh and Nagisa
the officer advice to go out and find
her own happiness and that initial
connection starts there uphill journey
to recruit people into the drama club
they're trying to revive from the get-go
you meet Okazaki's roommate you haste on
a horeb sana Hara does a good job to
bringing comic relief throughout all the
emotional strings being pulled
throughout the show with the
relationships Okazaki starts to form and
with his drunken father who treats him
like a stranger despite these family
problems the anime is actually quite
wholesome because you a sense of
satisfaction when continuing through the
plot through his school relationships
and his new friend Nagisa if you enjoy a
nice slice of life anime with a strong
sense of emotional self reflection then
I would highly recommend Clannad
[Music]
so what'd you guys think of this list
then if there are any other particular
videos that you want us to create then
please comment below and let us know and
of course leave a like if you've enjoyed
this video feel free to subscribe if you
haven't and hit the notification button
so you never miss out on our new uploads
we'll see you next time on vinnie tube
goodbye
[Music]